Speaker 1: We're continuing this discussion
of whether it's reasonable to go to someone
of a certain identity to ask questions about
that identity. How did it start? Well, last
week I got a voicemail, or maybe it was Monday
night. I don't remember last week or Monday,
I got a voicemail from someone saying, Hey, David,
I have some Jewish questions. Yiddish, actually,
what's the shekel? What's a shekel? And I answer
them. And then on Tuesday, the eggman called in
and said, David, that that's inappropriate. That's
anti-Semitic. It's like going to a black woman and
asking her to touch her hair. And I said, I don't
think so. I think it's logical that you would
go to people that you believe might have more
knowledge about something than you and you ask
them about it as long as it's being done in good
faith. But the man didn't like that. We have a new
voicemail caller. This we're going through every
identity. We had a Jewish man call in the Egg Man
to give his perspective. Now, a gay man called
in to say he welcomes people asking him questions
about homosexuality. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, this is rich from Palm
Springs, California, and I was just listening
to your piece where you played the Egg Man
saying that he thought it was disrespectful to
ask you about Jewish languages and change and
such. Yeah, and I agree with you. I think he's
wrong as a gay man. I have no problem answering
questions. I find a lot of straight people have
questions about gay lifestyle and terms and
stuff like that, and they're truly curious, but
they're not going to sit at home and Google stuff.
Speaker 1: I mean, maybe they would,
but that's not really an issue.
Speaker 4: And as long as it's
respectful and not just like some
ignorant jerk being an ignorant jerk. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So what I think is inappropriate
is once I was at once, I was at a brunch.
This was so awkward. I was at a brunch.
And someone upon. It was like a round Passover
time at some other, some other year around
Passover time. And completely unprovoked just
on the basis of figuring out I was Jewish
from from mentioning having been at Passover.
This woman says to me in a very antagonistic way.
Can you explain to me why the U.S.
government sends money to Israel?
And it's it's like I'm expected as a Jewish person
to defend the foreign policy of the United States.
And it was clearly bad faith. It was
clearly antagonistic. It's like going to
I don't know, is it going to a Muslim person
and saying, can you defend why the U.S. sends
money to Pakistan or Egypt or something like that?
That's completely bad faith. It was a completely
inappropriate question. I don't know. I'm not
the spokesperson for that. Why are you asking me?
But it's different. Hey, what is what is
what's shackled? You know what Schmeichel is?
I think that's OK. And I think it is all it
is all context. As the caller points out,
we have a great bonus show for you today. Ukraine
says Russia's offensive in the Donbass has begun
and is rapidly escalating. We're going to talk
about it. Florida Governor Ron DeSantis is trying
to strip Disney of self-governing power.
That doesn't sound like letting businesses
do what they want. We'll talk about it. And Sarah
Palin, as we've said it, she's trying a comeback.
She's running for a member of the house,
but she's running up against the problem,
which is that her star power seems to have
dramatically dimmed in her home state of Alaska.
Can she still win? We'll talk about it, all of
those stories and more on today's bonus show.
How do you get the bonus, Joe? It's very easy.
You go to join Pacman dot com and you sign up
and instantly you'll be able to listen to the
bonus show or watch the bonus show, whichever
is your preference if you're more an audio person.
You can listen if you're more a video person you
can watch. You could also play the video, but only
listen to it. I don't know why you would do that,
but you could sign up at Join Pacman ComCom.
Unidentified: We'll see you that.